تعود الاحداث لتشتعل هنا من جديد فبعد
مقتل الضابط الاردني عبد الرزاق الدلابيح
بيومين داهمت القوه الامنيه القاتل هنا في
هذا البيت لمواجهه افضل لموت ثلاثه رجال
من الامن العام ومقتلقات للزبيح ورغم هدوء
يعم المكان الا ان مشهد الحزن خيم على
ثلاث جنازات هنا بالتحديد تقودك الدماء
لمشهد المواجهه بين القوه الامنيه ومجموعه
من الارهابيين وما بين الرصاص طائش وموجه
قضى ثلاثه من رجال الامن العام واصيب
اخرون طبقت قواعد الاشتباك ورد الامن
بقتله احد افراد الخليه وبعد جمع الادله
الفنيه والمخبريه اكدت التحقيقات انه هو
قاتل الضابط عبد الرزاق الدلابيح الذي قضى
برصاصه اثراء اعمال شغب مفتعله في منطقه
الحسينيه ضمن عمليه ارهابيه خطط لها
لاستهدف القوات الامنيه
اليوم ليس كان البارحه
اطلب من جميع المواطنين الابتعاد عن كل
الاماكن التي تضم اعمال عنف وما بين
محافظه الطفيله ومادبا وعمان شيع
الاردنيون ثلاثه من رجال الامن وسط
مطالبات بالقصاص من الجناه من جهه والعوده
لاسباب تازم الاحداث من جهه اخرى
فردي ليس لابناء اللواء الحسينيه اي علاقه
في هذا الموضوع الحكومه
تركت المشكله من البدايه وما صار فيها
حديث مع المواطنين ولا حلت المشكله لذلك
خسرنا كانت كبيره من البدايه التصرف اللي
حدث هذا التصرف فردي ينعكس عن الشخص نفسه
عدم تدخل رئيس الحكومه ومماطله الحكومه في
القضيه كامله ادت الى هذا المشهد اللي
انتم تشوفوه الان واللي الان بلشنا نخسر
ابناء سواء في الجهاز الامني او من
المعطني احداث المواجهات الاخيره دفعت
بالقوه الامنيه لتعزيز وجودها حفاظا على
حياه المواطنين وفرض الامن خاصه مع اقرا
هذه مطالبهم في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه لا
تحتمل ذهاب الجميع الى نقطه تضيع فيها
الحقوق وتزداد فيها الاوضاع تازما من
مدينه الحسينيه جنوب العاصمه عمان عماد
العضائله العربيه